is meeting
as neither the chair nor Vice chair can
be present
um can we please have a nomination to
chair today's meeting
councilor Armitage uh I nominate uh
Council Armitage is nominated Heather
ligas
and councilor Hancock has seconded uh
our members content with that
members have indicated their contents
um Can counselor Liggett now please take
the chair
thank you and uh just while councilorius
is taking the chair um could I just
remind members to speak clearly and
directly into their microphones through
the meeting uh this will make it a lot
easier to follow for those participating
in the meeting via zoom and those
watching on YouTube thank you chair
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
thanks for choosing me to chair today's
planning committee meeting
we have three applications to consider
and as you can see there are no appeals
reports I'm happy with this and intend
to take the business in order set out on
the agenda
first item is apologies for absence have
we received any in advance uh yes sure
uh councilor M Jones who's been
substituted by councilor T Lacey
councilor K Rouse who's been substituted
by councilor s Pickering
councilor D roof who's been substituted
to Proud counselor p and cliff
we've also received apologies from
councilor P Elliott councilor a Powell
and councilor Jay Ridgeway thank you
chair
thank you Alan are there any other
apologies
and not have been received here
um right item two uh the second item is
Declarations of Interest members are
requested to declare the existence and
nature of any dissonatory pecuniary
interests and there are any other
interests not already on their
registered interests in any item on the
agenda and withdraw from the meeting at
the appropriate time
do any members have any interest to
declare
not have been declared to oh sorry
Council Armitage yeah I'm a tenant of
uh original uh but not up to North Wind
fields
and I I'm also on writtenald operational
board thank you
item three minutes sorry I didn't
realize um I'm also a tenant of written
thank you thank you councilor Pickering
uh item three minutes of the last
meeting we have the minutes of our
meeting held on Tuesday the 20th of
September 2022 are we happy that there
is a correct record
second of chair thank you all those in
favor
[Music]
all those against
the abstentions
motion has been carried thank you
uh thank you that brings us to the main
business for the meeting our three
applications before we start I would
like the Clark to explain to the benefit
of member speakers and those watching on
YouTube how we will deal with them
thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
the business this afternoon
the chair will introduce an application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
these have been published on the
council's website and hard copies have
been circulated to you
after this the chair will ask any
speakers to address the meeting there is
only one speaker registered today who
will be speaking on the second
application via Zoom
they will have three minutes to pull
forward their views
there'll be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the three minutes members
of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary to clarify any points that
they have
made
okay then meeting but they will not be
allowed to participate further from that
point
the chair will open up the meeting for
questions to officers a date by a debate
by the committee and finally
determination on the application by a
vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
finally members this meeting is being
live streamed from the council's website
and so as mentioned previously could you
please speak clearly and directly into
the microphones
a recording of the meeting will be
placed on the council's website for
please note that others may choose to
copy it
thank you chair
thank you the first application Ned
forward slash 22 forward slash zero zero
three eight zero forward slash FL
kilimash
um as you may recall we agreed to defer
this application at our last meeting so
the office is provided with additional
information to help us reach our
decision I'm pleased to say that they've
now been able to do this therefore I
intend to start our consideration
consideration of application for the
beginnings so that we can now consider
all the information together and going
to ask planning officers to tell us
about our late comments and to give us a
brief presentation showing any of those
and plans of the site I'll allow allow
the officers to complete presentation
consequently members could you please
reserve any points of order or questions
until about the process Until the End
thank you
thank you chair
um all the late representations have
been included in the late reps document
this application has been brought back
to committee as the information
requested by members in September has
now been provided the travel plan has
been submitted and Derbyshire County
Council highways have commented that it
is acceptable subject to condition
requiring the site to be described as no
parking in any tenancy agreement
um highways have confirmed that the
draft parking guidance document referred
to by the highways officer is at a high
level stage within Derbyshire County
Council it has not been seen by the
offices before you and as such officers
have given it no wait
details the fire safety plan have been
submitted however these have been dealt
with by building control at the building
regulation stage and are not considered
not a consideration at planning stage
the application site is located in south
of Sheffield Road and is outlined in
Orange on this slide
this is the red line plan submitted by
the applicants this plan also shows the
location of the secured cycle storage
proposed to the rear of the property
this slide shows the existing layout of
the property with shop and Retail
related storage on the ground floor and
residential accommodation on the two
stories above the applicant has told us
that shop sales are down particularly
since the covered pandemic and the
opening of new supermarkets close by
these are the proposed drawings
as requested by this committee a fire
safety strategy has been submitted
however this is not a material planning
consideration and must be dealt with by
building control under the building
regulations
next slide please this slide shows the
position of the building on the edge of
the area designated in the local plan at
kilimash Town Center this plan also
shows how close the building is to the
town center
the submitted travel plan confirms that
the application site is is a sustainable
location with services within walking
distance and cycling distance and this
part of kilimage is well served by buses
some of which stop at the bus stop
within 25 meters
as a consequence of its sustainable
location officers consider that
approving the application with no
parking is acceptable subject to the
implementation of the travel plan
the following slides research of those
shown at the site visit and are here as
a reminder
slide shows the shop with the surgery on
the right the narrow access to the rear
can be seen on the left of the property
and this slide shows how narrow the
access to the rear is
this slide shows Sheffield Road to the
West with the surgery and chemist in the
foreground
and this shows Sheffield Road to the
east
officers of the viewed as the proposal
is limited in scale it would not have a
harmful impact on the character and
functionality of the killer Marsh Town
Center as the services it provides are
replicated close by elsewhere it would
not result in the loss of important
social infrastructure and due to its
sustainable location close to town
center and bus routes The Proposal would
not have a harmful impact on highway
safety or parking in the area as such
it's recommended that the application be
approved thank you
thank you uh as no one has registered to
speak we now go straight to the
questions to the office about the
application I'd like to keep this part
of the proceedings focused on getting
clarity about any points that you're not
sure of once we've done this we can have
our discussion about the application
based on All We Have Heard and read I'd
be grateful if you could not move any
motions at this stage let's wait until
we've had the chance to make up make our
assessment also as the clock has
reminded us could we all speak clearly
and directly into the microphones
thank you
thank you thank you chair
um just just one because I'm only
struggling with this application on one
point and and I think part of the
problem is that when the local plan was
being drafted it was pre-covered and
covid has changed public transport a
hell of a lot and uh obviously the key
bit to here is sustainable travel
um and the bus routes in killer Marsh
have been decimated they're they're
thing completely infrequent to where
they were there's not a huge amount of
employment in killer Marsh itself and to
get anywhere where they do they need
access to cars so that that really is is
my key sticking point on this one and um
I'm wondering how how we mitigate that I
mean I get the idea of having the
tenancy document stating that there's no
parking that's perfectly logical but I'm
I'm struggling with the long-term
sustainability of of this project so I'm
I'm just really after a bit of guidance
from yourself if I can
well kilimash is considered a level one
um settlement in the district so it's
one of it is one of our most sustainable
settlements if not you know well yeah
one of the most sustainable settlements
uh so as such we do consider it as that
um the travel plan has um gone through
all the various bus routes and train
routes that are accessible
um how they can be got to by different
forms of public transport or um or
walking or cycling and is
clearly lays out that those those are
accessible so um as far as offices are
concerned we consider it to be a
sustainable location and therefore
subject to that travel plan and and
particularly the
um highways recommendation that it's
advertised as a no-car site we are um
happy that it it does meet those
requirements and is sustainable
a chair just to follow up on that I
think I think my key point is
I mean prior to covert I would agree
with you
um the problem is that I mean it's it's
a 45-minute walk to the nearest tram
place so that's not doable in Winter
likewise people are not going to be able
to bike in Winter and the buses I mean I
had a look um the timetables they're
they're a fraction of what they were so
as I say I'm struggling to reconcile the
sustainability of the public transport
side of it to kilimash to anyone who's
needing to go into Sheffield
or any of the surrounding areas it's not
like dronfield where it's got a train
station
um Clay Cross
is closer to the to the M1 in terms of
the Junctions so yes it is there it is
one of our level one settlements I doubt
its status will have changed but I think
it its ability to to service people and
particularly given
given the nature of the accommodation
it's people who are trying to get a foot
on the ladder or more than likely to be
I think I I'm really not reconciling
what you're telling me with what I'm
seeing in reality
well the traffic plan was written in the
last month between the last
um
planning committee and this one so as
far as I'm aware it's up to date and
we'd take you know that that's been
looked at by the highways Department who
also have that information in front of
them so but yeah we consider it to be up
to date
yeah if I just may add to that um as
Alice has pointed out the issues around
the sustainability of getting to to
other places but Alice has mentioned and
I emphasized the fact that killer Marsh
is one of your four most ascendable
settlements within the district so the
viewers offices would be that is where
development should be directed whether
it be housing or
other developments because that's that's
the nature of your sustainable local
plan and as officers and as Alice has
mentioned we are the view that this
development Accords with the development
plan as a whole and that this this form
of developed if it isn't going to go to
kill the marsh there's there is no other
more sustainable location within the
district so again as Alice has pointed
out we we recommend approval of the
scheme based on that chair albeit
acknowledging that Cass and Cox made the
point that perhaps links to other places
aren't perhaps as good as they they once
were it's it's actually killer Marsh
itself which is sustainable per se with
all the all the elements that would
normally be required to to live work
again Casio mentioned that opportunities
may be well Limited in kilimage but all
those opportunities there there are
shops post office religious facilities
pubs Etc
councilor Armitage
thank you chair
I'm much in agreement with what council
adcocks have to say uh the other thing
is can uh can you police the fact that
uh no uh cars are going to be allowed to
go around the buck and I fear you can't
and if you were to pass it could it be
made that there are some barriers big
enough for people to walk through but
not big enough uh for uh a vehicle to go
through I mean is this feasible
to put in the conditions
the rear of the property for parking and
that would be
um require planning permission
and so if they were doing it then we
would have enforcement
and control over that
because at the minute there isn't any
parking around the back
the point B
can it be enforced because somebody
who's got a job leaves early in the
morning and comes back late at night uh
and Parks his car the point I'm making
is surely on conditions we could uh make
it so you couldn't take a car through
Sheriff that was the the issue that
members felt was it was make or break
then you could condition that if you
chose but I would suggest if you felt
that was necessary that you put to pay
as Council Armitage had said you
required a scheme for the prevention of
cars to get to the Rios it was a
condition of approval so that would be
and bollards or barriers of some form
if if members are of the view that that
is
a fundamental issue on on which they
would wish to release the application
otherwise well uh in one of the
photographs it shows a red car parked
across a full path so I think something
needs to be done
Council Lacy
thank you Jay
um killer Marshall is my board so I'm
quite intimate with the site
um
this will in Cut there's no car
will be impossible to police and you're
going to get anti-social parking
in the doctor surgery where there's sick
people
and also the pharmacy the people who
need essential medications
so um
if they could park at the rear I would
have no problems at all with it but I
can't see how this no car policy can be
policed
thank you chair
councilor Hill
oh thank you I was just uh going to ask
Scott on the slide report there was one
I don't think it was on the previous one
about it being uh in the uh local town
area and we've got here as late comments
I know we're discussing the travel plan
but that slide showing that it's within
the town area we've got the doctor
surgery next to it then the other row of
shops and for our late comments another
one from a local residence
concerned about the location of the HMO
housing up to 15 people so really this
is a question further
um officers or officers uh
do they feel bearing in mind is the town
center and that there may be issues with
car parking that it is absolute
absolutely acceptable in the area
[Music]
that's why I've recommended the approval
okay I just wanted to double check
that's all thank you
anybody else any other questions
right then that just leads us to the
final part of the process our discussion
about what we've heard
um and what we would like think about
what we would like to decide before we
get any further I'd just like the Clark
to remind us about an emotions
yes thank you chair
please bear in my members that emotion
must be moved and seconded before a vote
is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then that Amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving emotion against
officer recommendations should comprise
the relevant planning issues and be
supported by evidence as necessary
if a motion to a reject officer
recommendation Falls or in other words
it is not passed that does not mean that
the recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further Motion in
favor of the officer recommendations
or a different course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
in terms of the timing of emotions these
should be moved and seconded after the
committee has heard read and discussed
the evidence before it
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached and will then invite
motions to be put
members will be reminded of this by the
clerk if they wish to propose a motion
before then thank you chair
thank you I'd like to open the floor for
debate
councilor Armitage
thank you chair I've been looking at
this uh
and
I'm not happy about the number of people
that are going to be in that building
we've had a a report from the Derbyshire
fire and rescue service and
they gave the following recommendations
then they follow whilst they may not be
enforceable now
it's that building if a fire starts in
the bottom there is one Escape Route at
one set of stairs
and I'm not happy that people will try
and get down those stairs and there'll
be some fatalities I am quite sure about
that uh there's been no mention of a
fire escape outside uh
and it's very tight if you can actually
get one in
unless I'm I'm not in favor of this
number of people Under One Roof
Gemma just um just make a point in in
response to that
the the report sets out chair that the
issue of fire safety is one that's dealt
with by the fire service through the
building regulations approval so the
advisors officers is to be very very
careful on the the weight that you place
on the issue of fire safety
and as as officers we would recommend
that that matter is best dealt with and
left to the building regulations where
it's the proper and appropriate way of
dealing with it I I understand fully
cancer armitage's comments and and the
reasons that he made them but in
planning terms that is a matter that's
dealt with by the legislation so I
strongly advise members chair to to be
very very careful about how much weight
they place on that and how it's dealt
with through the planning process
Council Hall did you want to well I'm
gonna Echo similar concerns to what
council Armitage is said
um
I mean could it be deemed to have a
negative effect on the surrounding area
this is what I was trying to get out
earlier I mean we've got a row of houses
it's in the Town Center we've got
doctors surgery right next to it and
very little parking
I'm just can't
I don't know a
property of that size for 15 people I
just have concerns that that's all
but but in the office's eyes could could
it be deemed to we reminded if we were
minded to vote against it to have a
negative effect on the set surrounding
area
yeah that's a that's a matter for
members to weigh in the balance in
considering the application all I'd ask
for an understanding of when members
take that decision
to to understand that the weight and the
evidence that you're placing on that
negative impact and that's for members
to to know to assess and take a view on
as officers of course our viewers set
out in the report and and our conclusion
is that it wouldn't have that overriding
and adverse impact
that's that's a matter for members to
weigh in the planning balance chair
well if we've got no more comments uh oh
Council Hancock
thank you chair I I share Council
armitage's concerns I think it it is
to me it's a very tightly packed
building to be fire safety and I totally
respect what officers are saying that
that's not our decision but it's our
conscience
um and I think I think that's a key
thing and at the risk of repeating
myself I I'm really struggling
to see how it is sustainable in terms of
travel and particularly given the the
reason that we've got in here for for
approval is to promote sustainable
travel options I I think that's almost
running contrary to what the the
application itself is
um and whilst
in principle I don't I actually support
a development of this kind I just don't
think this is the right building or the
right place and I think the lack of
parking is going to cause a problem and
again while it's not a planning
consideration I don't think this is a
sustainable business model on that basis
because they're very limited as to who
they're ever going to be able to put in
there
um or my my conscience sits with what
what council Armitage says in terms of
the fire things and as I said to me it
doesn't meet policy ss1 around the uh
around sustainable travel
um I think I I don't think I can support
it in all truthfulness
thank you
if there's no other comments we've heard
and read everything to Officer's
recommendations before us what is the
view of the committee on the application
I'm now opening the floor for motions
Council Hancock thank you chair I'm
going to move that we go against
officers recommendations
um under policy ss1 on the fact that
it's not sustainable the the I share
other concerns but we can't actually I
don't think we can put those in there
but I think that's the the key policy
one
I'll second that for the same reasons
thank you right we have a motion before
us Alan yeah just to be clear chair then
so it's to refuse the application
contrary to offers the recommendations
on the grounds that it's contrary to
policy ss1 and in the sense that it does
not promote sustainable travel
not the essence of it members
thank you in that case chair I'll now do
a roll call
councilor ancliffe
councilor Armitage
councilor Cooper
councilor hall for
councilor Hancock for
councilor Hartzell for
councilor Lacy for
councilor Liggett for and councilor
Pickering four
that's a unanimous chair the motion has
passed
thank you
all right move on to the second
application
Ned forward slash 22 forward slash zero
zero zero five seven four slash FL North
Wingfield
thank you
and I prefer professional Fair members
to the late comments report and the
admission of plot 71 and 72 from the
scheme along with the flood team
confirmation they have no objections to
the application
now this is application for the
Redevelopment of whiteley's Avenue with
a demolition of 16 dwellings and a
construction of 70 dwellings which are a
mix of 70 tax houses and bungalows
the scheme proposes a mix of 50 open
market and 50 affordable with a splitter
39 affordable rent and 11 share
ownership the local plan policy
requirement is for 20 affordable there
are no technical objections to the
proposals from the statutory consultees
and is recommended for approval with
section 106 contributions towards health
education and play provision
just having a slight technical problem
we'll catch up with the with Phil in a
second let's move the slide
[Music]
foreign
evelopment existing housing was
demolished in 2018 and it was for four
to one dwellings
thank you this is the application side
red plan
foreign
this shows the amended site layout
development will infill the open areas
that have been left following the 2018
demolitions and the development is in
three main Parcels of housing
the top of the screen as new called the
soccer powers and to be formed at
beadley close along with new housing
fronting onto whiteley's Avenue
Bungalows are located off Wayside close
which is accessed off the southern Loop
of whiteley's Avenue
and units are proposed to the rear of
Greenland close which back onto existing
Bungalows with a footpath to the rear
in the Southeast Corner plot 69 and 70
and now front onto the street and where
plot seven to 172 have been replaced
with an area of public open space
this is a zoomed in extract to the new
house in gumbili close which backs onto
the rear Gardens of existing housing and
meets the council's guidelines for
separation distances
parking is all on plot and units address
the junction with whiteley's Avenue
it's an extract showing the development
of Wayside close which are existing
Bungalows units 48-53 our new Bungalows
accessed by wayside housing would create
a new Street Front just to Whiteley as
Ashford Avenue 1a1 and three are the
existing houses
it's extract shows houses to the rear of
the existing housing on Greenland close
existing path there is to be retained
separation distance so in accordance
with the council's guidance
plot 63 and 64 artery Bungalows and some
replacement party prepared was for 14
Greenland close
6970 have now been reorientated to face
onto whiteley's Avenue and plus 7272
have been admitted and replaced with an
area of public open space
it's a street scene drawing for the
frontage of beauty clubs and whitelings
foreign
Junction with whiteley's Avenue and the
Bungalows of Alice View at the top of
the photograph
so the you North from white leaves would
be close to the left existing houses on
Carver Avenue to the right
it's photo looking off whiteley's Avenue
showing the rear fencing of houses on
Greenland close
finally it's a photograph looking
Northern whiteley's an existing
Bungalows to the left and to the rights
are located the new Bungalows accessed
off why cyclops thank you chair it's
just one other item we just like to
mention chair before
um
members go into consideration the
application as um Phil's set out chair
and as in the late reps because you get
some amended plans in that set out a
slightly different location of plot 69
and 70 to accommodate the concerns that
the llfa had in line with your current
procedures we have undertaken and
re-advertisement of that that will run
for two weeks chair so my recommendation
to members is that
um the application is approved subject
to the completion of that consultation
and any comments that are raised are
addressed by myself in consultation with
yourself chair we're not expecting any
um concerns because the two plants that
are now in place very much replicate
what there is at the moment put in line
with your same Community involvement we
are required to do that so that's that's
my recommendation chair hopefully
that'll be acceptable to yourself and
members
thank you Adrian uh we have one speaker
today the agent for the application
George Warner will be joining us via
Zoom as members you can ask him to
clarify any questions that have been
raised but remember your question should
only relate to the point which he has
already made
are you there Mr Warner
yeah good afternoon can everyone hear me
yes we can thank you can you confirm
this is your name and that you
understand the process if so you have
three minutes to speak
yeah correct or understood ready to go
okay when you're ready thank you
yeah good afternoon my name is George
Warner an architect at rgmp uh speaking
today to represent the applicant
rightnold homes in support of the
application
uh following on from your officer's
presentation and having reviewed the
planning committee report we're pleased
to know this application is recommended
for approval and consider the report an
example I've had to carry out the
required planning balance clearly and
concisely
as demonstrated within the report the
principle of development upon the land
was established with the granted
demolition Works back in 2018.
following the loss of houses stock on
this valuable Brownfield site the
proposed regeneration will provide a
carefully considered mixed tenure of
both affordable and open market
dwellings
35 much needed football halves will
contribute 15 towards the 236 additional
affordable dwellings required annually
by the local Authority this being in
line with the Strategic housing market
assessment early end update of 2017.
the development will complement the
recently completed external wall
insulation works the surrounding
properties along whiteley's Avenue and
upon completion will create a vibrant
new residential residential destination
within the village
care has been taken throughout the
design process to ensure the dwellings
respect to existing Urban grain a key
Focus being a successful integration
within the surrounding context in terms
of scale layout and materiality
there are no setting for objections from
Consultants to the application and we
have worked with all Consultants to
address all comments and queries on the
layouts
the site's been assessed thoroughly from
an ecological perspective throughout
through additional surveys and we'll
work closely with the lead local full
authority to address all flood risk
concerns so through a collaborative
approach the layout has been Advanced to
emit plot 71 and 72 which entirely
mitigate all flood risks from the scheme
in conclusion no material considerations
have been identified which indicate that
your panel commission should be refused
and through the careful and thorough
works of your offices and other publicly
interested parties all concerns raised
have been comprehensively addressed
throughout the determination process as
such we respectfully request that
Planning Commission be granted with the
recommended conditions imposed on the
subsequent decision noticed thank you
very much for your time
thank you Mr Warner uh there's anybody
any questions for Mr Warner
no I don't think we've got any so thank
you
right have any members got any questions
for the officers
thank you chair uh just one and it's
only for clarity in my own peace of mind
the realignment of plot 69 and 70 does
that actually remove the overlooking
concern of the neighbors that at number
32 it does it's actually probably an
improvement in that perspective thank
you
councilor Armitage
right so
on uh what was the concerns around plot
7172 uh do I take it that there is a
difference uh in the ground level
between 69 and 70 uh which would make
them uh not vulnerable to flooding uh or
I just wonder if if there's any sort of
revetment to stop uh any flood or from
this uh back if it overflows
foreign
as the um present plots and the ones
that were emitted were due to the the
team's concerns around in the call but
so there's no there's no flooding issue
with the proposed scheme as it stands
where is it called
um in this case it's shown
you probably see it's actually in your
community report
it's next to where there's an extract at
uh
page 43 you can see
um
figure 12 where it shows where plot 71
or 72 originally prepared was the blue
hatched is is a line of the line of
record which was causing the issues with
the support team well that's now that's
now supposed to be open space so say
there are no no footing containers at
all from foot team right device location
shares is on the screen again and the
the call works is the line of the the
blue dash if you like and I'm sure Phil
if I'm wrong but the the concern was the
the call work particularly where it hit
the the road and how that's dealt with
the surface water how it back
okay
actually
um back backed up into that area it's
now shown as POS as Phil said
so that's right that's a real idea when
when was the uh LFA report uh when was
it actually done I mean some of them are
years out of date
is this a fairly modern one the issue
with the with the flooding was they
wanted
um quite a bit more work doing in terms
of the information around those two
plots
um and the the amount of money and the
time that was spent there was
um the importance I think was was the
need of the housing to come forward
rather than replace any further so it
just takes that um issue about the
equation by committing those two parts
I'm sort of edging around it because I
don't want to see a situation like we're
having played across I mean who's
responsible for keeping this back clean
well for example
it's monitored by the flood team on a
fairly regular basis at a discussion
with a plug team and it's one of the
ones that they do go around and monitor
right okay and the other thing is if I
can just ask another question the uh
splays on these uh Records uh streets
and pull this up uh for vehicles coming
in and going out they're not
although they they look okay uh as
regards the visibility from here
there will be all right just a grassy
cap to cut and uh is there anything in
there that uh you know uh is a provision
to make sure that those areas are
capturing back I'm into the highways did
they question the highways have raised
no issue regarding
um overgrowing grass verges and they've
got no objections
this the standard highway conditions
that they want included okay and then
gonna just been worried about till we
start to turn it around okay there's no
no objections from refuse either now
thank you
have any further questions for officers
all right I'll open the floor for debate
then please thank you
right we'll move directly to motions
Council thank you chair I'm happy to
support officer's recommendations on
this with them with the caveats that
Adrian added earlier about that extra
change thank you
okay just before it let me take note
just to be um clear with councilor
Hancock and Alan that would be if we do
receive any any comments that
um dealing with those is delegated
myself in consultation with yourself
which should not not anticipating any
because of what what Phil said about the
location those two dwellings but just
would mean that we keep the protest
moving forward but it would involve your
self-chair if we did receive any
before we move to the vote can I ask
Alan to
um read it out make sure that we're
clear thank you
essentially as uh Adrians just suggested
that it's to support officer
recommendations to approve the
application subject to the consultation
exercise which is currently taking place
uh with the final
um sort of Delegation uh in terms of the
conditions
um resting with the the manager the
planning manager in consultation with
the chair
that's satisfactory
yes obviously if we don't receive any
further comments then yeah
the agent would just be a delegation to
itself if we did receive any comments
then it would be delegated to to
ourselves and and we would need to take
a view as to what if any alternative
action a referral back or whatever we're
not anticipating that would take place
and ideally wouldn't take place
sure just to be clear does that what
Adrian has just said that include the
renegotiation of the 106 one is that's
been applied for that's currently in the
in the process gen and that would be
because there's two less dwellings that
would be a minor reduction that we're
just getting the most update figures
from the various Consultants but yes yes
it would
um how's the big Rings right in there
but that would just take account of the
two the lower number of dwellings
thank you uh right we'll move to the
vote and I think we're going to do this
through roll call well thank you chair
councilor and cliff
councilor Armitage
councilor Cooper
councilor hall for
councilor Hancock for
councilor Hartzell for councilor Lacey
for
councilor ligate for and councilor
Pickering four
that's unanimous chair the motion has
passed
thank you right the third application
Ned forward slash 2022 forward slash
99423 forward slash FLH Ridgeway
we now come to the our third and final
application for the day once again in
line with normal practice I'm going to
ask the planning office to tell us about
any late comments and to give us a brief
presentation showing any photos and
plans of the site
I will allow the officer to complete the
presentation good members please reserve
any points of order or questions about
the process Until the End thank you
thank you there's no late comments in
respect of this application share which
is seeking consent for a single story
side and a single story rear extension
and we'll just have some a review of the
the drawings to explain that in a second
this is an application that's located on
a out building to a domestic property
that's located both in the green belt
and the Moss Valley Conservation Area
both matters that members need to take
account of in this instance chair due to
the size of the extensions officers of
the view it's not an appropriately
developed in the green belt but because
of the specific three reasons set out in
the report and The Limited impact on
openness to take into account of
officers are recommending approval of
the scheme just to go through the the
drawings chair the application site is
the area outlined and colored in in
bayesia members may be able to make out
the the primary dwelling and then the
out building that lies to the north of
there in plan form the main building is
the building just below some cross with
the outbuilding above and the extensions
comprise a single story side extension
that's in replacement of a larger single
story garage that currently exists and
on the rear a single story extension
partly Gable roofed and partly flat
roofed that sits at high ground level
than the front level as we saw on the
site which is yesterday it's to come off
rebuilding it an upper story that would
comprise single story accommodation only
and the building chairs we saw yesterday
a highly decorative building but not
listed but highly decorative building in
the Moss Valley Conservation Area
and the proposal as you see there Chase
for a single story side extension
forming
a garage and then single story rear
extension partly Gable route and partly
flat roofed
I'm just an aide Memoir photo for
members that we saw yesterday this is
the front of the building and you can
see at the far left of the building
where the original flat roof garage was
that's replaced by the smaller our
single story extension and then the
single story to the rear is beyond the
building and the Garden area it just
gives a flavor of what we saw yesterday
that's helpful to members thank you
thank you
as I wanted ready to speak we're now
going straight to questions to the
officers again I'd like to point out the
proceedings focused on getting clarity
about any points you're not sure of
thanks
anybody any questions for officers
will open the floor for the debate then
please
again there we go
um right we'll move on to motions
I'm happy to support officers
recommendations on this one
well we have a motion before us
across to Allen okay chair so the motion
is to um support and to approve the uh
application in London office of
recommendations
uh councilor ancliffe for
councilor Armitage or
councilor Cooper
councilor Hall
or councilor Hancock for
councilor
councilor Lacey or
Liggett
and councilor Pickering four thank you
chair uh unanimous the motion has passed
thank you
uh item eight matters of urgency I have
no urgent business so it now can declare
the meeting closed and thank you for
your attendance